on peut être il est elle à la fois moi
j'ai écrit dans un de mes livres j'en ai
trop écrit deux livres mais enfin dans
un de mes livres est écrit que dans le
fond la logique de l'identité était la
logique moderne au bout d'un processus
éducatif je suis un homme ou une femme
de gauche ou de droite ceci ou cela et c
est qu au contraire ceux qui étaient
préalable à la modernité pré moderne ce
qui sera pour moi la post modernité
c'est les identifications multiples et
et pas où donc du coup on peut être ceci
et cela en même temps et moi je connais
des quantités attitude et quantité de
personnes qui ne vont pas se reconnaître
dans ciel mais qui vont être peut-être
dans des moments différents il ou elle
pourquoi non mais cela pourquoi non mais
cela au travers d'un acronyme de cet
envoi la moto et vous que c'est pas
utile enfin
c'est une attitude de vieux
réactionnaire que je demande
[Musique]